Planned Parenthood has suffered massive
layoffs
less than two weeks before the
anniversary of
the decision in Dobbs to overrule Roe v
Wade just two weeks before according to
the Boston Globe
uh more than 100 employees of planned
parenthood's National staff received
notice that they would lose their jobs
why are they losing their jobs is it
because donations to Planned Parenthood
dried up no donations to Planned
Parenthood spiked after Dobbs that was a
major historic fundraising opportunity
for Planned Parenthood they took
advantage of it every big live in the
country was saying give your money to
Planned Parenthood
so they had the money
but demand cratered they no longer had
the customers
they no longer had quite so many mothers
coming in saying hey I'm in a desperate
situation and then these Predators at
Planned Parenthood say oh I've got the
answer murder your baby and give us a
little bit of money for it too we'll
we'll do the kit job if you just pay us
that's the problem
it was not a matter of funding it was
not a matter of investment it was a
matter of demand demand totally cratered
and here's what the what the staffers
are saying and telling the Boston Globe
Planned Parenthood said the pivot was
necessary to meet this moment after
Dobbs but the staffers who requested
anonymity due to the sensitivity of the
subject matter often described
disillusionment with the organization
they included Union and non-union
workers some who had been laid off or
left for other reasons as well as some
who are still working there they're
disillusioned you know
turns out that when you work for an
infanticide Mill it's not all it's
cracked up to be uh you know I thought
we were working with people with
Integrity here I thought we were signing
up with high-minded noble people who
make it their mission in life to
slaughter the most innocent vulnerable
persons on planet Earth and then what do
you know they're kind of deceitful could
you imagine they don't they don't have
the strongest moral code those
professional murderers of babies the the
article goes on
Planned Parenthood struggles with the
right level of transparency said another
National staffer who is laid off it felt
like they were trying to give us a lot
of transparency about the process like
we're making this pivot these are some
of the things that are changing but
there wasn't a lot of transparency
around like the vision and where things
were going based on those changes
Planned Parenthood is so opposed to
transparency that they
Lobby against laws that would make women
who are about to murder their babies
look at ultrasounds
if you are looking for transparency I
would not recommend looking at Planned
Parenthood
the entire business model of which
relies on hiding and disguising the fact
that your baby is actually a baby the
whole business model relies on on
distracting you from seeing what is
obviously true so that they can make
money and get whatever
[Music]
satanic kicks they get out of murdering
little children
you're not going to get transparency
there you're not going to get
high-minded idealism you're not going to
get Noble comportment and behavior
and now
you're apparently not going to get a job
this is a great story because it proves
something that conservatives did not
believe for far too long which is that
we long have said politics is Downstream
of culture or the movies in a culture or
the music the art the the behavior or
the Traditions the rituals that all
matters of course that all matters
but it can be said with just as much
seriousness and truth that culture is
Downstream of politics because the law
is a teacher what happened here right
now go to geniusell.com Knowles as you
might know we are big fans of our
friends over a genu cell especially the
founder who's a Coptic Christian from
Egypt who fled and came over here for
the American dream their product is
fabulous don't take my word for it Ella
from Rockford says quote I have both age
and acne spots and this stuff is
actually fading both of them this Serum
is worth every penny Ella is raving
about the famous Dark Spot Corrector
from geniusell a must-have after months
of record heat and humidity sunspots
brown spots discoloration even red
inflamed patches all disappear in front
of your very eyes here's the Gen you
sell amazing guarantee you will see
results on day one or your money back
if it happens on day two you can get
your money back take advantage of
geniusell's most popular package which
now includes the Dark Spot Corrector
plus the classic geniusell eye bags and
puffiness treatment
with immediate effects all at about
seventy seven zero percent off right now
go to genucel.com
Knowles start looking years even decades
younger tomorrow say goodbye to dark and
liver spots bags and puffiness under the
eyes and Crow's feed at genusl.com
Knowles that is genucel.com Knowles
what happened here is not that people
got together and they just had a change
of heart organically from the culture
and society and so they decided to stop
killing their children it's that the
heavy hand of the law came down and made
it much more difficult to murder
children and then fewer people did it
that's what happened
you know sometimes we've been told
by the politics is Downstream of culture
Fanatics the the who make an idol out of
that concept that actually if you pass a
law that's not going to change anything
at all no no the law doesn't affect
Behavior the law doesn't create
incentives no no unless the the change
in law is motivated by just a change in
culture which Springs up organically
from the society then it's not going to
have any effect at all well here's proof
that that's a lie that isn't true you
can change the law even if the culture
which is completely dominated by
liberals in Hollywood in the academy in
lower education in everything everywhere
you can change the law and you will
still get that effect Planned Parenthood
is still going to have to lay off
workers because fewer fewer women are
going to show up to murder their babies
because the law says so and the law is a
teacher
what liberalism does
Classical liberalism and libertarianism
and modern liberalism and all of its
derivations what it does is it tries to
de-politicize everything so it creates
these these contrasts between you know
politics and culture
the the law
the government and society and free
associations but
we live in a republic we live in
government of the People by the people
for the people at least in theory
so what's really the difference between
those two things
that that distinction gets a little bit
blurry it gets a lot blurry actually and
really that what that distinction serves
to do is is merely a polemical purpose
to discourage authentic political action
and to disguise authentic political
action under the guise of it being
depoliticized through the economy or
just through private business or just
through the culture do you really
believe this is what some of these
people would say they would say that
when Google Twitter and Facebook
completely dominate the Public Square
and cut out conservatives from speaking
and censor all sorts of ordinary things
and true things even right before an
election they censor the hunter Biden
laptop story and it
changes the results of the election
according to post-election analyzes and
surveys
but what what these types of people will
say is well that wasn't a political
action that was just private Enterprise
that was just private businesses doing
whatever they want to do that's not
political and if you don't like it build
your own Google build your own Twitter
what are you talking about we live in a
self-governing republic if you can
control the Public Square you control
the political order
what Google Twitter and Facebook did is
intensely political it's some of the
most overt heavy-handed political action
I've ever seen in my lifetime maybe in
the history of the United States
and it's even more Insidious than some
authoritarian government worker doing so
because Facebook Twitter and Google have
even less accountability even less
transparency and they're not obliged to
uphold the principles that we have
passed that are our four four Bears have
passed and ratified into law the
protections of the Constitution and
laws in many cases
the law is a teacher baby it works and
it has real crucial urgent effects it
saves
hundreds it's saved hundreds of
thousands of babies lives there will be
hundreds of thousands of people from
this year alone who will be born because
some justices on the Supreme Court
decided to change the law culture be
damned no actually culture be changed
for the better because the culture is
affected by the laws boy what a great
clip that was now make sure
that you subscribe to the Michael Hall's
YouTube channel we'll see you next time